(bright music)
Welcome back, Dr. Levine.
He is going to talk about some issues related
to dermatology and skin.
So Gary, welcome back and you can take it away, sir.
No new disclosures for you.
Now, if you're going to have a lecture like this,
it's important to reference some important people,
helpful in providing some of the pictures
that you're gonna see.
Dr. Charles Phillips, a colleague of ours in Greenville
who moved on to Mexico.
A Dermatologist, Dr. Richard Usatine,
who is Doctor Dermatology in Family Medicine.
He's down the road in San Antonio.
A good textbook is the Clinical Dermatology by Habif,
recently updated in 2020.
Some of these pictures come from the federal government,
the CDC, and from the Jefferson Medical College Image Bank.
If you want to know what things to study
for the boards in terms of dermatology,
kind of go back to the future, all the way back to 1999
where the curriculum guide was published
in the AAFP Journal.
Most of the entities we had in 1999
are still with us in 2024.
The information about them may have changed,
but the rashes and skin lesions are still there.
And if you want to know what to study,
that's a good place to start.
We're going to talk about macules, papules and nodules,
plaques, pustules, vesicles and bullae
There are a few wheals and scales and crusts,
erosions, fissures and scars thrown in there.
And we're gonna go throw a lot of this stuff on warp speed
and we'll finish within the hour.
When you see a question in dermatology on the boards,
they tend to come in one of two ways,
questions with pictures and questions without pictures,
and we'll see both of those to help you today.
Now COVID is with us
and there's actually dermatologic issues related to COVID.
Almost 20% of some patients COVID
will have dermatologic findings
and most common are the maculopapular/morbilifirm rashes,
followed by the COVID toes,
what they call pseudochilbain or pernio-like acral lesions.
And here we have some pictures of those
with pernio sitting there on the left.
The reticular form lesions were more purpuric,
those occur more in your sicker patients in the ICU setting.
Our first question for you, case number one.
45-year-old male presents with a chronic rash present
over his knees and his elbows.
Which of the following represents
the most likely diagnosis here?
Is it Tinea corporis, psoriasis,
mycosis fungoides or Bowen's disease?
Oh, look at this.
(attendees applauding)
Yep, our patient has psoriasis, very good.
This is a plaque and scale-like disease,
psoriasis, chronic lupus, tinea corporis,
Paget's disease, lichen planus, Bowen's disease,
cutaneous T-cell lymphomas, Pityriasis rosea,
syphilis, ichthyosis, a number of things
that present with plaques and scales.
Here we have tinea corporis,
a well-defined border with central clearing.
Pityriasis rosea scale-like lesions here.
If you're lucky to see the herald patch,
that may be the beginning of that disease process for you.
Bowen's disease, precursor for squamous cell carcinoma.
Ichthyosis, fish scale-like skin,
tends to be hereditary and all over the body.
We had some inter-practice with this.
Lichen planus there's a vivacious plaque-like lesions there.
Lichen simplex chronicus,
itches a lot, scratches a lot.
Some people just scratch and they get neural dermatitis
and they get plaques and scales
at the site of their excoriations.
But our patient has psoriasis, typical psoriasis.
Oval, erythematous, plaque-like lesions
often at the site of trauma.
Look for them on extensor surfaces, elbows,
knees, scalp.
Patients can get systematically sick with psoriasis.
With arthritis, often they'll have pitting fingernails
as a clue that it's psoriatic arthritis.
Chronic plaque-like psoriasis,
the most common thing we're gonna see,
but there are others as well.
How do you treat it?
When there's not a lot of involvement,
we use topical steroids.
Calcipotriene which is a vitamin D analog.
Calcitriol, another analog.
Calcineurin inhibitors like tacrolimus.
Tazarotene, been around for a while.
Coal tars, even aspirin and phototherapy.
But when it becomes more involved,
that's more the purview of the dermatologist,
they use different kind of light therapies.
And if there's systemic involvement,
disease modifying agents similar to what you might use
for rheumatoid arthritis and any one of those biologics
or anti-TNF agents that you see advertised on TV
without ever a price tag because they're super expensive.
Number two, can you see this lady?
Okay, there she is again.
65-year-old lady presents with this painful rash
on one side of her face.
Which of the following therapeutic modalities
would be most beneficial in the initial stage
of this illness?
Prednisone, valacyclovir, silver sulfadiazine
or gabapentin?
And you're gonna work with Valtrex, good.
Why? What's wrong with this patient?
Herpes zoster, got shingles, right?
These are bullous lesions.
They start off that way, herpes simplex, herpes zoster,
bullous impetigo, dermatitis herpetiformis,
second degree burns, bullous pemphigoid,
pemphigus vulgaris, to name a few.
This is bullous pemphigoid.
These bullied tend to be tense,
non-painful often the elderly.
If you push on it, they don't spread.
If you push on it and they spread
and the tissue comes off, that's called Nikolsky's sign.
That's pemphigus vulgaris
and that's bad news for your patient.
Second-degree burns blister, first-degree sunburn,
third-degree ulceration.
Dr. Dash made me reiterate the fact
that we don't treat this with silver sulfadiazine anymore.
We don't use that for a second-degree burns.
Silvadene's no longer what we use.
Erythema multiforme, typically are target lesions,
but they can blister emboli as well.
Our patient has zoster or shingles
or reactivation of the Varicella-zoster virus,
usually involving a single dermatome, but occasionally more.
Before you see the rash,
there's often burning and fever and itching
and if you can diagnose zoster before the rash occurs,
then your reputation is great
and your community for years and years to come.
Look for vesicles, varying size at a red base.
They come in crops, they crust over in about 2 to 3 weeks.
And you may see postherpetic neuralgia more often
in the elderly and more often if there is significant pain
during the rash itself.
If the rash all comes at the same time all over the patient,
then notify homeland security.
That may be the first case of smallpox
that you have ever seen.
How do we treat herpes zoster?
Analgesics, things like wet compressors
and the big three antivirals choose amongst acyclovir,
famciclovir or valacyclovir.
It doses higher to a Dr. Weismiller will tell you later,
treat genital herpes.
What about steroids?
Prednisone, they may decrease pain initially,
but may increase the likelihood
of a secondary bacterial infection.
We used them more in the past than we do now
and they don't decrease postherpetic neuralgia.
If you get postherpetic neuralgia,
treatment modality similar we talked about
in the pain lecture earlier,
anti-convulsants, tricyclics, opioids,
even nerve blocks.
We now have a vaccine to prevent this.
Shingrix, which replaced Zostavax,
which is not quite as effective.
Shingrix is a recombinant vaccine given in two doses
for patients over the age of 50, 90% effective.
You can give this if they've had shingles before.
If they have shingles now, wait for all the lesions
to fully heal before you consider giving this.
Is not for people who are pregnant or breastfeeding.
Case number three.
Look at the hand.
25-year-old male, known HIV infection lives
in substandard housing as we provide for our residents
and students and presents with a generalized pruritic rash.
Which of the following represents the best treatment
for this condition?
Is it prednisone, hydroxyzine, permethrin 5% or abacavir?
Oh, we're three for three, Permethrin.
Why? What's wrong with this guy?
He's got scabies.
He sure does.
These are erythematous and pruritic,
these are papules, miliaria,
atopic dermatitis, urticaria, may look papular,
insect bites, scabies, the eruption of HIV,
the pruritic papules and plaques of pregnancy.
Here's a patient with atopic dermatitis.
Notice involvement the flexor surface
and the cubital fossa as opposed
to psoriasis on extensor surfaces.
Urticaria looking kind of papular here.
We all know why you never give Benadryl to a bee
because it'll ruin their hives.
Scabies as we see in our patients.
Hypersensitivity reaction to the mighty mite,
Sarcoptes scabiei.
We don't provide it with indoor plumbing,
so as it lays and moves around their surface of their skin,
it lays eggs and fecal pellets, which you call scybala
and those cause a reaction.
The board's not gonna ask you about scybala.
The mites like to move at night, so things itch more than.
You can find the burrows if you're lucky.
Where do you look for them?
Finger webs often or anywhere in the body
and the genital region in adults.
And here's a scabies, couple scabies burrows.
If you're finding a hard time being sure that they're there,
what you do is take a felt pen
and you go ahead and color over the burrow,
and the ink gets into the burrow,
you wash off the top of the skin
and you'll be able to see the burrow.
Then you take your little blade and scrape it
and look in the microscope for the mites,
the eggs and the feces.
And if you're lucky and the patient is not,
you may see the mite that are on your left and the eggs
and fecal material on the right.
Norwegian or crusted scabies
is an overwhelming infection usually in HIV patients.
Not all that itchy, however.
How do you treat scabies?
You launder bedding, clothing worn within 72 hours
or you stick it in a bag and suffocate 'em.
Treat the patient, their contacts,
anybody living in the same household with permethrin 5%.
And you treat from the neck down,
the stuff usually doesn't get into the scalp
and you may or may not repeat it in a week
depending on what you want to do.
Ivermectin is effective for Norwegian scabies.
If you can find a leftover from the COVID epidemic.
Benzoyl peroxide lotion, a few other things,
Eurax available over the counter.
This is Rhus dermatitis, also known
as toxicodendron dermatitis, also known as poison ivy.
And this happens when you contact the sap from the plants
in this particular plant family.
Poison ivy, poison oak, poison sumac, mangoes.
If you live in Hawaii,
a lot of the dermatitis is in peeling mangoes
as you see in that area.
And of course, the ubiquitous Japanese lacquer tree
that we all have in our backyards.
And you see poison ivy.
So linear lesions, you may see vesicles,
redness may take up to eight hours after exposure
or even a week before you see these things come on.
How are you gonna treat it?
If you're gonna decontaminate it,
you know, with soap and water, you gotta be quick.
Once it's occurred, you can treat it with compresses.
Oral antihistamines don't work all that well.
Steroids do, but they typically have to be high potency.
And more recently, the recommendation is systemic steroids
as long as 2 to 3 weeks of prednisone,
so that you don't rebound over that period of time.
You can inject triamcinolone,
you may have to do more than once as well
to keep that treated.
Moving to contact dermatitis,
you can almost kind of envision where the nickel band is
around this person's wrist.
Case number four.
Look at that carefully.
Look at the hair follicles carefully.
This is a 55-year-old male congressman,
complained of a new rash on his chest
after returning from a business trip with a female lobbyist.
He admitted to spending an inordinate amount
of time having meaningful conversations
with her in a hot tub.
Of course, while masked and socially distancing.
Which one of the following would you recommend
for the management of this condition?
Oral cephalexin,
no pharmacologic therapy, but stay out of hot tubs,
oral Bactrim or topical clotrimazole?
See how you do.
And you have voted for B, which is correct.
Why? What's wrong with this patient?
Has hot tub folliculitis, right?
Those of you who thought about Bactrim
weren't all that far off, okay?
If you thought it was a staphylococcal folliculitis,
which is not.
So what is folliculitis?
A superficial bacterial infection of the hair follicle.
When you get a lot of these things together,
you may get a furuncle.
Those furuncle go to town and kind of coagulate,
you get carbuncles and then you get purulent drainage
from multiple follicles.
And here's one furuncle waiting for Dr. Bard Parker
to come and liberate his pus.
Sycosis Barbae, folliculitis in the the beard area.
Most folliculitis is staph aureus
and your Bactrim folks that would help with it.
But in the hot tub,
and some of the hot springs like in Nevada
and California, it's pseudomonas and aeromonas.
Canada species, sometimes remotely,
even non-TB microbacteria.
The good thing about folliculitis,
usually gets better on its own,
but when there's extensive involvement
or long lasting will treat it with antibiotics.
Warm compresses help
if there are furuncles or carbuncles
and the valve invo...
Excuse me, avoid shaving in areas
where the folliculitis is present.
With hot tub folliculitis,
stay away from the contaminated water
that usually does the trick.
In severe cases, ciprofloxacin,
which covers your gram negatives,
would be a reasonable antibiotic to use.
Mild staph folliculitis.
If you're gonna treat it, you can use mupirocin
or topical clindamycin if it's more severe
and using oral therapy.
If it's not MRSA, dicloxacillin or cephalexin,
if it's MRSA, Bactrim, clindamycin, or doxy.
Pseudofolliculitis barbae is not a folliculitis,
it's an ingrown hair.
Hair is cut too short and sharp, grow backwards
and form inflammatory papules.
The treatment of that is very simple.
You do what I do, and you don't shave.
(attendees laughing)
Impetigo seen mostly in children.
A contagious, superficial bacterial infection.
Primary impetigo occurs on normal skin.
Secondary in patients with things like abrasions or eczema.
There are a couple different types of impetigo.
Nonbullous impetigo is the most common form.
Begins a papule, progressed to a thick golden crust.
In the past, this was beta-strep,
nowadays, 90% of it is staph aureus.
Bullous impetigo.
These are vesicles that become flaccid,
yellow initially then turbid.
This is staph aureus exclusively.
Strep impetigo, again, rarely see in these days
can go along with poststreptococcal glomerulonephritis.
The board could ask you that, but I don't think it will.
How do you treat impetigo?
Limited number of lesions.
Use Bactroban amongst others.
If there are more of them, oral treatment
if you don't think it's MRSA, again,
cephalex you think it is.
Clindamycin, Bactrim or even linezolid.
This is a patient who has erysipelas.
This is a cellulitis, a beta-strep cellulitis.
These folks tend to be pretty darn sick.
Often they're septic, high fever, mental status changes
if they're elderly.
The lesion has a well demarcated erythematous border
and these folks often need admission for IV antibiotics.
If they're not all that sick,
then you can use oral medication
that will work for strep infections.
All right, case number five.
Moving along.
You see this one okay?
You've probably seen this one a lot in the past.
16-year-old female would like to be treated
for this facial rash, not responding
to over the counter cleansing preparations.
Her high school prom is three months away,
she wants to look good.
She's not sexually active.
Which one the following would you recommend
for the management of this condition?
A topical retinoid alone.
Topical clindamycin alone.
A topical retinoid with benzoyl peroxide
and oral doxycycline or isotretinoin?
And we're gonna go with C, which is correct.
And what's wrong with this patient?
What she got?
She got acne.
Acne vulgaris, right?
She has inflammatory acne vulgaris to be exact.
Here we see a couple of pictures, patients with acne.
Acne is an androgen-mediated disease.
It happens when our hormones kick in, our androgens kick in.
The androgens simulate sebum production from the follicles
and keratinocytes proliferate.
They make keratin, which plugs up the duct of the follicle,
bacteria that stays in the area, cutibacterium
is the current name for it.
It proliferates in that plugged follicle
and produces inflammation
through inflammatory substances it secretes.
That's what causes what we see in acne.
The board may ask you about different kinds of acne lesions,
closed comedones or whitehead, open comedones or blackheads
that's due to the plugging of the follicle
with the keratinocytes.
With inflammation, you get nodules or papules, or pustules
and eventually different kinds of scars
that are difficult to treat.
Here we have a patient with acne,
inflammatory acne on the forehead,
another one that we saw earlier around the mouth.
This patient has an inflammatory cyst
and the dreaded black rectangular eye syndrome
that we often see in dermatology textbooks.
Most common areas of acne
are where there is sebaceous gland activity.
That's why you see in the face,
the upper chest, upper back, and the upper arms.
So how do you treat acne?
We're gonna talk a little bit about this in more detail
because acne is the most common skin condition seen by us
and by dermatologists is we treat comedonal acne
with a keratinolytic agent.
If there's mild inflammation with it,
we continue that and add benzoyl peroxide
or a different topical antibiotic.
With moderate inflammatory acne like our patient,
we're going to add to the keratinolytic agent
and benzoyl peroxide a systemic antibiotic.
And those who have bad nodulocystic,
we can use the big gun isotretinoin
or used to be called Accutane.
What are topical keratinolytics we have?
Tretinoin or Retin-A, adapalene, work about the same.
Adapalene is better tolerated and now available
in combination with benzoyl peroxide or with Retin-A,
you have to do it at different time as benzoyl peroxide
because of deactivation.
Again, retinoids tend to be irritating,
especially if you start 'em at high dose.
Tazarotene been around for a while, is teratogenic
as all retinoids have that capability.
A new one on the market, trifarotene 4th generation,
less skin irritation and more expensive.
Azelaic acid is keratotic and anti-inflammatory.
Also depigmenting.
You can use it to treat hyperpigmentation.
Moving on to topical antibacterials,
benzoyl peroxide has been around for a while.
The good thing about it is there's no resistance yet
of the acne bacteria to BP.
Usually given twice a day, it's a peroxide
so it can bleach things, so be careful with that.
We sometimes combine it with other topical antibiotics
so we can use the other antibiotic
without worrying about resistance.
No longer recommended that you use things
like erythromycin and clindamycin
and tetracycline topically by themselves
only because resistance is high, use it with BP.
Metronidazole gel can be used for acne as well.
Dapsone available more for women
with acne lesions and it doesn't cause glucose-6PD issues
when you use it topically.
Systemic antibiotics.
Try not to use them more than three months.
Tetracycline has been, the one you used over time,
of course, not in children.
It's not as effective though as minocycline
and doxycycline.
Minocycline is effective,
has allowed systemic side effects
including lupus-like reactions and for that reason,
not used all that often.
Doxycycline easy to use around food
is photosensitizing, so be aware of that.
There's a new one on the market, sarecycline,
again, more narrow spectrum, also more expensive.
Now, how many of you are aware of the use of a Wood's lamp?
And Wood's lamp's a good thing to have in your armamentarium
for many diseases, you know, recommend you carry
that in your pockets at all times.
I know Dr. Weismiller usually recommends
with get togethers like this that over the course of time,
you make friends with those people sitting around with you
maybe go out and have dinner or something.
If you do that and you find a liking for that person
before you take that relationship to a higher level,
take out your Wood's lamp, have them pee in a cup for you
and scan the cup.
And if the contents fluoresce,
they're probably taking doxycycline for chlamydia
and you don't want anything to do with them
for the rest of the course.
(attendees laughing)
Other antibiotics he used for acne include erythromycin.
Again, azithromycin, Bactrim.
Be careful about resistance to those antibiotics.
Again, three months systemic antibiotics,
you can switch abruptly from oral to topical
without tapering.
Again, don't use topical and oral antibiotics together
unless one of those is benzoyl peroxide.
Oral contraceptives.
There are a number of them FDA approved
for treatment of acne.
It's the progestin component that's important here.
You want to use one that's non-androgenic.
And these four have been recommended
and approved by FDA.
Spironalactone and anti-androgen, again, use it in women.
It grows the breasts in men.
It's not FDA approved, however, for acne.
There's a new cream that came out, clascoterone,
which is a topical antigen receptor inhibitor.
So kind of like a topical spironolactone of sorts,
which you can use both in men and women.
What about isotretinoin?
This is a medicine that can cure acne given over
a 12 to 20-week course.
Lots of side effects, the worst being that
is highly teratogenic.
So if you're gonna use this with a patient,
both you and the patient have to register
with the iPLEDGE program.
And that is a pledge that you and the patient
and that you don't let them get pregnant
that need to be on contraception and/or avoiding sex
and not get pregnant on them.
There are life-based treatments for acne.
Again, something the dermatologist
will typically tend to use.
Not all that greatly effective.
If you enjoy being a surgeon,
you can use your Comedo extractor and suck out those zits,
a lot of fun.
If you have abscesses, you can drain them
or you can inject them if they're cystic with triamcinolone
and make them shrink down quicker.
Topical tea tree oil is an alternative treatment for acne.
There is some data that it works,
but it's effective and it's kind of slow.
Who should you send to the dermatologist?
Refractory lesions despite
the appropriate therapy you're giving.
You think they're bad enough to need isotretinoin,
you might wanna let them start it
and then continue if you need to.
Acne scars are hard to get rid of.
As soon as you're really good at dermabrasions
and things like that and let them work on that.
Leaving acne vulgaris, we have another acne.
This is acne Rosacea.
Here we see more rosacea, forehead, cheeks are involved.
Here, we have more involvement of the nose.
Rosacea is seen more often in women over 30
of Celtic ethnicity.
We don't know what causes it.
There is some enthusiasm for it being due to Demodex mites.
It's chronic, intermittent, involves forehead, cheeks,
nose, around the eyes.
The board may very well ask you
the primary features of rosacea.
Erythema, you can see a flushing with that.
Papules and pustules and telangiectasias.
Those are the three primary features.
You can also get something called
a rhinophyma bulbus red nose.
Our friend WC Fields over there, had that.
He was a big drinker and thought,
well, maybe the drinking caused that, but it doesn't.
But drinking does causes the rash
to flush and become more apparent because of vasal dilates.
So spicy foods, alcohol, niacin,
anything that vasodilate you
will make the rosacea rash come up.
So if you want to diagnose it,
if you're not sure you have it,
give your patients some niacin, watch them flush,
say, oh, you have rosacea, right?
How do you treat it? Topical antibiotics
for the papules and pustules.
Metrogel, you can use that.
Don't use the vaginal preparation,
use the skin preparation.
Azelaic acid, benzoyl peroxide, clindamycin.
For the erythema and flushing,
you can use brimonidine or you can use oxymethazone.
Carvedilol can also help prevent flushing in patients.
For again, the nodular areas if they're worse
and topical therapy doesn't work,
the same antibiotics we typically use for acne vulgaris.
And retinoids can also be used in severe cases,
actually, retinoid can also work for rosacea.
Now this is a patient who has seborrheic dermatitis
and acute Seroquel deficiency, I think.
(attendees laughing)
A little bit of seborrheic dermatitis again here,
kind of a greasy-looking rash in the face
or in the sternum area.
We tend to see seborrheic dermatitis in young infants.
We can also see in adults,
you see in adults coming outta nowhere.
Think about HIV.
Think about Parkinson's disease.
In Parkinson's disease,
L-dopa may actually improve the dermatitis as well.
For typical young kids with seborrheic dermatitis,
you can use topical antifungals or low-potency steroids.
On the scalp, antifungal shampoos like selenium sulfide
or ketoconazole work well.
Perioral dermatitis.
This is kind of an acne lookalike, a mimic.
Typical story here is she says, "Well, doc,
I got this rash, I put some of the steroid stuff on it
and this is what I got."
And it's typical.
With mild involvement, we use topical metronidazole
like we do for rosacea, topical erythromycin
or pimecrolimus.
More than mild, same oral antibiotics we use for acne.
Lupus erythematosus, nasty rash, nasty disease.
As they say, the mask of the wolf.
Lupus can be chronic cutaneous lupus, subacute or acute.
Most patients with lupus will have mucocutaneous lesions
at some time during their illness.
The butterfly malar rash being the most common,
it tends to spare the nasolabial folds, for some reason.
Sun exposure makes this worse, it's photosensitive.
You see another young lady who has a lupus rash.
This is discoid lupus.
So how do you treat lupus?
Keep 'em out of the sun.
Stay away from cigarettes and aggravating drugs.
Topical steroids usually more potent
than we usually use on the face.
You can use topical calcineurin inhibitors,
systemic anti-malarials like Plaquenil,
and even methotrexate if it's not responding.
Case number six.
The case of the spotted man.
21-year-old male pale spots on his back and his upper chest.
Despite treatment with a topical agent,
they're now essentially unchanged.
These areas should now be treated which of the following,
Benzathine penicillin G, if you can find it.
Pimecrolimus, oral fluconazole or prednisone?
And we're gonna use Diflucan, good for you, good for you.
Why? What's wrong with this guy?
He has tinea versicolor, right?
Okay.
These are hypopigmented lesions.
Pityriasis alba is all above vitiligo, tinea versicolor,
post-inflammatory hypopigmentation.
These are all hypopigmented things.
Here we have a child with pityriasis alba.
You can see the hypopigmentation,
the forehead around the cheeks.
Don't know exactly what causes it,
don't know exactly how to treat it.
Often we do a topical steroids,
tends to get better over time.
Here's a patient with vitiligo, fairly extensive.
This tends to come in combination
with other autoimmune diseases.
So think about it with B12 deficiencies in thyroiditis.
Tinea versicolor, which our patient has,
fungus of multiple colors caused by Malassezia species
when it converts from a budding to a mycelial form.
That happens with heat, humidity, steroids, et cetera,
and where there's high sebaceous activity.
So who gets this?
Younger people typically in the summer.
In the summertime, they're tanning elsewhere
and not over those lesions,
and they make 'em even more obvious for you to see.
They start as circular maculas and enlarges.
They start off as tan or brown lesions, eventually,
hypopigmented as they get older.
A pottery scale means they're active.
Get your Wood's lamp out, shine it.
It's usually a yellow fluorescent over the area.
How do you treat 'em?
Limited amounts of disease.
Topical antifungals, selenium sulfide,
terbinafine, Selsun Blue.
More extensive lesions, oral involvement
like itraconazole or diflucan,
stay away from oral ketoconazole because of the liver.
If they have a lot of lesions,
you can prophylax them against recurrence
with ketoconazole or itraconazole.
And tinea versicolor is in the Tinea family.
Tinea means nothing more than fungus.
We define them by sight.
Tinea capitis in the head, tinea corporis in the body,
tinea pedis in the feet.
Tinea versicolor, multiple colors,
tinea gladiatorum in high school and college wrestlers,
tinea incognito in FBI agents,
(attendees laughing)
or folks who steal signs for football teams.
Here's tinea corporis.
Notice the well-defined margin.
Here's tinea incognito.
No, it's not FBI agents, this is tinea treated with steroids
and now it's kind of hard to figure out what the heck it is.
This is erythrasma.
The board loves erythrasma, always has a question on it.
And erythrasma shows up in the same places as tinea,
typically under the breast and the groin area,
and the axilla kind of acts the same way as well,
but it's due to corynebacterium, not fungus.
If you get out that Wood's lamp and shine it,
it's a coral pink, coral red fluorescence, really pretty.
And that makes the diagnosis.
If you find that you treat 'em with topical macrolides
or if it's worse, oral macrolides.
Tinea capitis.
Here, we see loss of hair from tinea capitis.
If it gets severe enough
and you get a real bad inflammatory response,
we call it a Kerion, with a K,
not with a C like vultures, like a K.
The board may try to trick you on tinea capitis.
The trick is,
they want you to treat this topically and don't buy it.
Tinea capitis is oral treatment, griseofulvin
or terbinafine of different formulations
and different lengths of treatment.
Itraconazole, fluconazole will also work.
With a Karion, you may wanna use steroids
to decrease that inflammatory response
while you're treating with an antifungal.
And you can prophylac others in the household topically,
but don't treat the patient topically.
Traction alopecia.
Here, that's braided too tightly
and you have some hair loss as a result.
Androgenic alopecia, a male pattern baldness,
often sometimes seen in women.
And this is patchy hair loss called alopecia areata.
Also an autoimmune disease process
associated with thyroiditis and vitiligo.
These cares come off pretty easy.
You can pull one out, look in the microscope
and look for an exclamation point here.
That is, it tends to be narrower at the proximal end
and distally or it should be narrow, it tends to be bulbous.
Sometimes you can see loss of scalp here completely,
sometimes total loss of body hair,
we call the last one, alopecia universalis.
How do you treat this?
Corticosteroids, injections or topical therapy,
even systemic steroids.
Topical minoxidil, neuro minoxidil.
As a hypertensive agent, you can use it topically
to grow hair on folks.
Wigs do a good job in waiting for the patient to get better
and most of them do within about a year,
50% will have limited hair growth back.
10% though may not.
Pediculosis capitis.
That's always of interest to us.
Here we see the perpetrator, the Head Louse,
posing for her prom picture.
You're kinda cute, I think.
How do you treat head louse?
Pyrethroids are the first line agents,
but there's resistance in some places to this.
Malathion, benzoyl alcohol, topical ivermectin,
even oral ivermectin, permethrin with Bactrim
has been used for this.
Important thing for us to know as family docs
is children who have head lice
once you start treatment, don't need to stay home.
Even if they have some knits still present,
they can go to school, they're not gonna affect anybody.
But treat on the patient, treat close contacts,
those who share bedding or in the same household.
This is melasma, we have talked about hypopigmented lesions.
Melasma is hyperpigmentation often associated
with pregnancy called the mask of pregnancy.
Case number seven.
26-year-old male dermatology resident presented
with your office about a new patch of warts on his penis.
Funny that you should ask,
my girlfriend has some of these umbilicated papules
on her bottom as well.
Most likely cause of this lesion is,
treponema pallidum, herpes simplex,
human papilloma virus or molluscum contagiosum virus.
This one's a little hard.
Let's see how you do.
Molluscum contagiosum.
What does our patient have? Molluscum Contagiosum.
Oh, what's this?
(attendees laughing)
Well, going back to molluscum.
No matter what the lesion looks like,
if they say umbilicated papules,
there's nothing else it could be, okay?
This was a resident of mine
when I was in Kentucky in Lexington.
Went down to Destin, Florida for vacation,
came back with this says,
he has the largest genital wart in history,
wants to take his picture for the Guinness Book of Records,
which we did.
And biopsy him too.
Didn't hurt him.
Pathologist calls back,
plant fiber looking like cauliflower,
so he didn't get sent into the Guinness Book of Records.
But genital warts can look like cauliflower-like lesions.
And this one is real.
Warts are due to HPV infection, 150 types.
Type one, plantar warts, type six and 11, genital warts.
16, 18, 31, 33 are the bad actors
that cause cervical cancer.
How do you treat genital warts?
Patients can treat 'em or we can treat 'em.
Patient treatments include podofilox, imiquimod
or sinecatechins.
They're over a cycled treatment plant, also expensive.
Or they come to us and we can freeze 'em,
put acid on them or cut 'em out.
We used to use something called Podophyllum resin
and tincture of benzoin, smelled so good.
CDC doesn't want us to use that anymore.
They say it's too tissue toxic.
But it was fun.
The day went nicely after that.
These are common warts.
We teach residents that if you follow skin lines,
the skin line will stop at the margin of the wart.
If it's a callous, they'll usually go through the lesion
and that's how you can tell a callous from a wart.
Here's some more plantar warts, big ones.
Here's a callous, actually ulcerating in a diabetic patient.
But again, with callous skin line typically goes through,
warts that typically stops at the lesion.
Can you treat warts with duct tape?
I don't know, but I would recommend if you do that,
put a little bit of compound W under the duct tape,
it might work better.
This is genital herpes, again,
it's our up with vesicles and ulcerate.
Dr. Weismiller told us about how to treat that
with acyclovir, famciclovir, and valacyclovir.
This is molluscum, our patient has molluscum.
Double-stranded DNA poxvirus, skin-to-skin inoculation.
Children get it all over the place.
If you see a child with it in the genital region
and elsewhere, they're probably just self-inoculated.
But if you see a child with only genital lesions,
that would be somebody you worry about abuse.
Adults have them in a genital area
because it is sexually transmitted.
How do you treat molluscum?
You can leave 'em alone if you want,
they'll go away eventually.
But while they're there,
then there's potential to spread it to others.
You can trial them, you can correct 'em.
Just don't do anything that's gonna really hurt the child
or they won't come back to you for all the good medical care
that you need to give them later.
Case number eight.
The case of the golden dome.
68-year-old man sent in by his daughter concerned
about a small growth on her father's scalp.
Which of the followings most likely diagnosis?
Keratoacanthoma, dermatofibroma, sebaceous hyperplasia
or basal cell carcinoma?
And you thought it's a basal cell, and that's right.
Good job again, folks.
This is a basal cell carcinoma.
Modular lesions, basal cells, squamous cells,
keratoacanthoma, sebaceous hyperplasia, melanomas,
neurofibromas, they're all in there.
This is sebaceous hyperplasia.
Looks a little bit like what a basal cell might look like.
It has some telangiectasias,
but they're confined within the lobules.
Usually these are multiple.
Here's the keratoacanthoma.
A looks like a volcano with keratin in it.
There's a question of whether these are pre-malignant
for squamous cell carcinoma.
Basal cells are the most common skin cancer in men,
often over age 40, 50.
Often the head and neck region,
they can stay small for many years
and then all of a sudden kind of spurt.
A diagnosis is by taking them off.
Nodular basal cells are the most common,
thankfully, the least aggressive.
Superficial, sclerosing, pigmented basals
and we'll see pictures of all of them.
So here is a nodular basal cell.
Here is another one more close up.
Look at telangiectasias, not confined to within lobules.
Another one eroding in front of the ear lobe.
Here's one that's superficial.
Here's the one that's sclerosis or scar-like basal cell.
The treatment is by eliminating them.
Excisional biopsies are often adequate.
You can correct them or cryo them if they're small.
If you're dealing with a larger lesion
or in a high recurrence area like the nose or the eye,
the margins are not clear, they're large again,
we have to worry about conserving tissue,
then send them to Mohs for Mohs micrographic surgery.
Radiation therapy can be used for non-surgical candidates.
Imiquimod, 5-FU.
And there's even a medicine, vismodegib
that can be used for metastatic basal cells.
That's fairly new.
Actinic keratosis.
Here we see a man with multiple AKs.
Oftentimes you can feel these
before you can even see them.
More often in the elderly,
fair-skinned individuals on sun-exposed areas.
So the head, neck, forearms, hands behind the ears,
look behind the ear lobes.
Rough scaly patches, small, multiple,
usually don't hurt, usually don't itch.
But why do we worry about 'em?
And because they're pre-malignant,
they turn into squamous cell carcinomas.
Not all of them do, certainly, but we worry about 'em.
How do we treat 'em?
Freeze 'em, that's a lot of fun to freeze 'em
or curate 'em, or laser them if you have a laser machine.
Or you can give the patient a prescription
for topical 5-FU, imiquimod, even diclofenac gel,
ingenol or the new ones, tirbanibulin,
can't pronounce that.
Again, tend to be expensive agents
and they'll apply them readily
and then the lesions hopefully resolved.
Bowen's disease, again, squamous cell carcinoma in situ.
Here's a keratoacanthoma again, looks like a volcano.
And here's a squamous cell carcinoma.
The big kahuna himself.
Precursors, again, AKs, maybe keratoacanthomas,
cutaneous horns, Bowen's disease.
They occur on disease or injured skin with radiation
or immunosuppression, they tend to blossom.
I have a patient who has a liver transplant
on immunosuppressants and keeps on popping up with these.
You diagnose them if you want, by a shave technique
or a punch biopsy.
And then the surgical excision is the treatment of choice.
If they're small, cryotherapy
or electrodesiccation/curettage will work,
radiation in difficult to treat areas.
Case number nine, we're getting through this.
Look at these, case number nine, lesions.
55-year-old man found to have these skin lesions
at the time of a routine exam,
has a lot more than just these two, by the way.
Which of the following
would be most reasonable course of action?
Treatment with topical 5-FU, observing these lesions,
excisional biopsy with wide four centimeter margins
or referral for Mohs micrographic surgery?
And you're gonna observe them, good.
Why? What's this person have?
Seborrheic keratoses,
old age barnacles as we used to call them.
These are pigmented lesions,
intradermal nevus, melanomas, SKs, Kaposi's sarcoma,
cherry angiomas, pigmented basals or pigmented lesions.
Here we see a cherry angioma, very characteristic.
If we see a patient come to clinic or in the hospital,
we take all the medical students and show them this,
so they can at least diagnose one skin condition
by the time they graduate.
Hemangiomas.
See these often, they tend to bleed readily.
So do these pyrogenic granulomas,
don't get into one of these unless you're prepared.
They tend to bleed.
This is an atypical dysplastic nevus.
Look at it carefully.
Here's a malignant melanoma, look at it carefully.
Looks a lot alike.
And that's our problem
is trying to differentiate the two of those.
You're probably not gonna miss this melanoma,
the nodular component there on the left, particularly.
Who gets melanomas? Non-Hispanic Caucasians
in their 50s and 60s, men more than women.
Problem with these things
is that they metastasize early and widely.
Thankfully, a lot better treatments now
than we didn't have before.
So who's at risk for melanoma?
Large number of atypicals, other skin cancers.
Congenital giant nevus, a family history,
immunosuppressed, radiation exposures.
There are different melanoma subtypes.
Superficial spreading is most common.
There are nodular, lentigo and acral lentiginous melanomas.
And we'll see some pictures.
What to look out for in diagnosing a melanoma?
Remember the A-B-C-D-U of melanoma.
Lesions that are asymmetrical.
The border is irregular, not well-defined.
Color is variable.
Diameter of over six millimeters,
the lesions changing over time,
what they call the ugly duckling sign.
This one looks different than the others
on the same patient.
So look out for that one.
Here's a superficial spreading melanoma,
a nodular malignant melanoma,
a lentigo maligna, these are again,
lesions that are macular rather than papular/nodular.
Acral lentiginous in the nail itself.
Look out for those.
What are some characteristics of that?
Older patient, dark color to that streak.
One nail involved, not multiple, wide, irregular margins
and pigmentation in the periungual area.
I have a number of patients, African Americans
who have multiple vertical streaks.
That's normal for them.
But if you see one guy or one patient, just one of them,
and it's regular at that male margin, boom,
that's not normal and if you biopsy and treat it.
With melanoma, the thickness determines prognosis.
So any biopsy you do needs to be full thickness
for diagnosis.
The more thicker it is, the more worse the prognosis.
Treatment for melanoma is a wide local excision.
Doesn't have to be four centimeters,
you don't have to create a crater in that patient.
Usually four millimeters is typically wide enough,
but you want to also look at the sentinel node in that area.
And immunotherapy rather than chemotherapy
is the way to go now for melanoma.
These are SKs like our patient has, numerous ones.
And if you're gonna biopsy one worrying about a melanoma,
do it full thickness.
You can punch it if you need to.
If you're certain it's an SK,
you can leave it alone and watch 'em
or you can use cryotherapy, or curettage on them.
The board may ask you about the sign of Leser-trelat,
it has in the past.
This is a patient all of a sudden develops all these SKs
for no reason.
This tends to be associated with internal malignancies,
particularly the GI tract,
particularly adenocarcinoma of the stomach.
So be wary of the sign of Leser-trelat.
This is dermatosis papulosa nigra,
an SK variant on the skin.
Don't be too aggressive in treating these
and cause scars in your patient.
Skin tags are another SK variant.
Our last case, case number 10.
Can you see this?
39-year-old woman complained of a lump on her back,
gotten bigger and smaller over the past several years,
occasionally some cheesy-looking material.
So you tell her that the material within the lesion
is most likely which of the following?
If you get this right,
you've gotten all 10 of these questions right.
No group has ever gotten 10 of these questions right.
So the most likely thing within that lesion is the keratin,
is it sebum, is it pus or is it cheese?
Oh, the late voters took over this election.
(attendees laughing)
Good for you.
It's keratin.
It's not sebum, it's certainly is not cheese,
even if you're from Wisconsin.
These are epidermal cysts.
We also call them sebaceous cysts, epidural cysts,
or epidermal inclusion cyst.
Most in common kinda cyst we see,
they have that central punctum,
that's how you can identify them.
The cyst wall produces keratin, not sebum,
the keratin is greasy and smelly, it's sebum.
Some of these things will rupture spontaneously
or they can become inflamed spontaneously.
If they're inflamed and they're uninfected,
then we don't treat them and choosing wisely suggest,
don't use antibiotics if they're inflamed, but not infected.
You can inject triamcinolone, as hasten resolution.
Excision is best done when they're not inflamed.
If they're infected and fluctuant
then, of course, you're gonna drain them
and use antibiotics if they're surrounding cellulitis.
And those antibiotics you might use are those
that you use to treat staph and strep infections.
This is a lipoma.
Nobody's gonna miss this one.
This is a keloid, a nasty looking keloid.
Keloids are hypertrophic scars.
We can treat them with intralesional steroids
with improvement,
but it's hard to inject the steroid in.
Takes a little bit of work for those
and it takes multiple injections over time
to make a difference.
This is a neurofibroma, also look for cafe au lait spots.
This is a hereditary problem.
And xanthelasmas, you can see them in the corner
of the eyes, lipid deposits,
they don't always associated with a hyperlipidemia
and they don't always get better
if you treat them with things like Lipitor.
So that's it for your run through dermatology.
Thank you very much, Dr. Levine.
(bright music)